joined now by the transport secretary
and Marie trevely and Mr villian thank
you for joining us on the program this
morning did the chief whip resign last
night
so you've just answered your own
question there you have reassured
everyone that uh Wendy Morton and Craig
Whitaker her Deputy are still in post
which is good news they are no that
wasn't my question important members of
the government didn't ask you that did
she resign last night
uh not that I'm aware of no
so she didn't resign at any stage and
then went then was convinced to be back
in post
so I I wasn't there I voted uh early in
the lobbies and then had important uh
security issues to deal with at the
Department of Transport uh so I didn't
follow the machinations in detail I'm
afraid I was busy doing my job uh but as
it's clear they are both in post and
that's good news
is it appropriate that MPS are
manhandled
I uh well as I say I wasn't there but I
have seen not the point the photograph
but Australian is going to be much
easier if you answer the question let me
answer the question okay I will uh I
don't think it's ever acceptable for any
party and we have seen this happen
before where uh whips perhaps uh overeg
uh their encouragement to get people to
vote in the appropriate way that is that
is never right the one thing that our
Parliament is uh so revered around the
world for is that we allow each of us to
vote with our conscience and indeed with
our government on important matters
yesterday was an opposition day debate
and uh we uh won that debate and the
opposition day uh vote lost their vote
okay do you condemn whoever man handles
people through the lobby yesterday so I
have no doubt that Mr Speaker will look
into these issues and it is for him uh
to make the final examination I haven't
seen any footage Beyond Chris Bryant's
photograph but it is never acceptable
for people to be uh manhandled or
bundled into voted do you condemn
whoever did it
well as I say I will leave it to Mr
Speaker to
um
well as I've just said it's never
acceptable uh for anyone to handle it we
should be able to vote uh absolutely as
we see fit on behalf of our constituents
and they are the ones who hold us to
account
um was it a vote of confidence in the
prime minister
I know yesterday was an opposition day
uh debate and the labor party were
trying to uh use a parliamentary tool to
try and hijack the order paper that is
never acceptable so what it was was a
very important vote uh to ensure that
the government uh did not allow labor to
do that it's a tactic that has been used
in the past and previous governments
have also always made sure that those
votes are not won by the opposition
what's going to happen to those MPS who
didn't vote with the government
uh so I haven't spoken to uh the chief
whip this morning I thought I might let
her sleep in at the uh situation is
always very clear the the
Parliamentary managers will uh discuss
with colleagues who uh didn't vote with
a three-line whip uh why that was
sometimes they're a very specific uh
constituency reasons or indeed health
reasons and I know that uh the
appropriate discussions will go on as
they always do in these situations and
if there is a sense that some uh were
doing so for uh not reasonable reasons
uh the appropriate discipline will be
enacted but I would imagine most have
very strong constituency reasons if they
were unable to vote with the government
apparently the chief whip didn't vote
so as I say I haven't seen the list it's
quite often the case that the whips
themselves don't vote on both sides
that's quite common
okay um prime minister didn't originally
vote but then we were told that she did
vote
um and we were told by Downing Street
um in fact tomorrow was told by Daniel
Street at 1 30 this morning when you
finally got your ducks in a row that it
was a confidence vote and though the MPS
that didn't vote with the government
will be disciplined does that mean
they'll lose the whip
well as I say that will be a decision
that the business managers make no doubt
today as they speak to those as is
completely normal uh when uh colleagues
don't vote uh with the government uh
Direction uh those discussions are had
reasons are discussed as to why that was
the case and discipline uh or indeed not
uh delivered accordingly and we will let
the uh whips office and ministers do
that in due course
why did Sue Ella bravaman get sacked
so she resigned in her letter which put
out yesterday set out that she felt that
she had fallen below the standard by
breaching the minister of Code by
allowing documents to be shared before
appropriately in in an unsecure way and
she felt that she had you know let
herself down and therefore as she is
someone who has always worked with the
highest standards she is a woman of
Integrity she felt she had to step down
no she was forced to step down as we
know we can see that from the letter
um the Prime Minister if she'd wanted
her to stay she would have stayed or
perhaps it was Jeremy Hunt who wanted it
to go and then somebody who supports
Rishi sunak can be put in her post
so uh government needs to get on Sue
Ella resigned and Grant chaps was
appointed he is a man with a very broad
experience in many government posts in
fact he was my predecessor in transport
a man who understands the complexity and
the seriousness of security issues and I
know that he will do an excellent job in
picking up and managing those important
issues that the home office has to look
after
he's also a man who said earlier on in
the week that the Prime Minister for her
to be able to remain in post it would be
like threading a needle in the dark
well he wasn't a member of the
government when he was speaking of the
week now he is and I have no doubt
because I know Grant very well that he
will be an incredibly hard-working
member of the cabinet and I shall look
forward to working with him
yeah but he doesn't think she can
survive as prime minister
he is now uh the he is now the Home
Secretary uh which is an incredibly
difficult uh job and he will I know get
right stuck into it today and make sure
that all those issues that we need to
work on together to protect our citizens
to work on those issues uh uh on the
short straights uh The Wider questions
that we do in security uh are ones that
he is absolutely focused on we have some
really important and difficult issues
that we are all dealing with and what we
need to crack on with is making sure
that we do that and Grant will be a
great addition to the team
okay so just to clarify for me what was
it that first attracted the prime
minister to the rebel supporting uh
Rishi supporting
um back venture
sorry I didn't enter so he went
correctly on me sorry
okay I was just asking what first
attracted the prime minister to uh a
rebel uh who had been rallying the
troops against the Prime Minister who's
also a Rishi supporter why on Earth
would she put him in one of the great
positions of office
so uh I I would imagine I haven't had a
chance to remember what she wanted was
someone with uh experience who would be
able to come in and manage the
incredibly difficult issues that the
home office has to deal with every
single day it's a 24 7 job that one and
Grant has as I say enormous government
experience here obviously uh was uh
transport secretary before I was and she
will know that he can act you know very
short notice pick up the reins and
manage the many complex issues that
there are there including of course uh
you know dealing with the short
straights an issue that I'm going to be
working closely with on those Maritime
security questions
Steve Baker who is an influential back
venture as you as you know but just for
the benefit of our viewers went uh on TV
yesterday speaking to one of my
colleagues saying that he'd been told by
Downing Street to say that swella
Braverman would be back imposed by
January
so I I'm afraid I didn't see that and
I'm not part of that what I uh can see
and knows the cases that Grant is Home
Secretary and that we all in government
in the prime minister's cabinet are
focused absolutely on supporting Jeremy
Hunt to stabilize the finances so that
we can get on with delivering the
services that are so important to our
constituents making sure that having uh
determined to fund the energy price
guarantee not only for our uh
constituents and in homes but also for
all our businesses so that we didn't see
a catastrophic uh failure of our smes in
particular that we make sure that we
demonstrate the city how we're funding
that and continue to deliver those
Frontline service that are so important
to our constituents
people up and down the country as you've
just been saying there are struggling to
feed their kids and we've got excuse me
politicians who are pushing and shoving
each other
um somebody who has been criticizing the
Prime Minister uh only a few days ago is
now one of the most important offices of
state two senior cabinet ministers have
been sacked in less than a week
um it's embarrassing
so politics is about looking forwards
and delivering and that's what we need
to do there are many very difficult
situations ahead obviously we have uh
the support that we continue to give to
our Ukrainian friends as the ongoing
Russian invasion and those battles uh
you know come into the winter months and
that's why the defense secretary has
been in Washington working with our U.S
allies to support that we have to make
sure we can deliver this energy price
guarantee so that uh you and I and
indeed everyone more importantly who are
vulnerable and who are managing uh tight
budgets know that this government is
working alongside them I was pleased to
hear the triple lock for our pensioners
confirmed yesterday uh on the levels of
inflation these are really important
matters and what we have to do is work
together and government is absolutely
focused on delivering for our people I
am of course today okay bringing in
minimum service levels service levels
legislation which will ensure that even
uh if there are strikes there cannot be
an ability to bring down completely our
transport networks this is really
important to support those exactly to
say those hard-working people who need
to get to work nurses get into a shift
children getting to school business
people getting to their business
meetings these are situations that we we
cannot allow our Transport Systems to a
grind to a halt so we're bringing this
in so that we have a fair focus on those
who use the services that we provide to
make sure that they can always keep
moving these are really important
government activities which will keep us
keeping the country moving and growing
okay Mr Rebellion I know you to be a
woman of Honor are you not embarrassed a
little bit this morning about what went
on yesterday
as I say I wasn't in the lobbies but I
am shocked to uh hear that the
descriptions of what went on as I say uh
we are uh well respected across the
world as a parliament where democracy uh
and freedom is at the heart of what we
do and I hope that Mr Speaker will be
investigating closely as I'm sure he
will to ensure uh that uh these these uh
scenes and individ situations do not
happen again what I want to make sure we
do also is deliver uh for our
constituents that's what's so important
we need to grow our economy we need to
ensure that we can deliver the
incredibly important public service that
we can draw in with investment so that
business can grow because it is with
growth and perhaps was absolutely right
with growth that we can do more for our
constituents for our fantastic Public
Services okay I'm going on holiday for a
fortnight tomorrow will this trust still
be prime minister when I get back I
believe you'll find she will be yes okay
let's see let's see it's good to talk to
you thank you very much nice to see you
and you